recent research shows a majority of
parents and teenagers check their mobile
devices at least every hour nearly 50%
of parents and more than 70% of
teenagers say they feel the need to
respond to text and other notifications
immediately concerns about the risk of
tech addiction are bringing together
former employees of some of Silicon
Valley's most prominent companies the
truth about tech initiative aims to
raise awareness about the downside of
constant connectivity by engaging tech
companies health officials law makers
and consumers James Stiers the founder
of Common Sense Media and Tristan Harris
is a former design ethicist at Google
Tristan is also co-founder of the Center
for Humane technology they are
spearheading the truth about tech
campaign good morning to both of you
great to be here Jim you've worked on
this with other kinds of media so what's
the central goal here the central goal
for us is to do a multi-year campaign
that educates parents kids and everybody
about the addictive quality of cell
phones and other devices and also to
come up with solutions and that includes
going with Tristan to the industry and
saying let's make design changes first
on is the key at the center of this
basically so the psychological feed that
dopamine gives you I mean is it really
hardwired into the brain yeah we talk
about addiction we tend to think oh this
is just happening by accident culturally
like what are the kids doing these days
but we miss it and as I know but the
truth behind the screen the truth about
what's happening on the other side of
the screen is that this is happening by
design there's a whole bunch of
techniques that are deliberately used to
keep the autoplay watching on video on
YouTube to keep you watching the next
video
or streaks and snapchat to keep kids
hooked so they feel like they have to
keep this streak going and all parents
know about this and so we have to raise
the public conversation and so we
partnered up to do this initiative you
are at Google you were one of the
insiders just on when did you realize we
have a problem here back in 2013 I made
a presentation at Google saying that we
as Google have a moral responsibility
and shaping two billion people's
attention their responsibility a moral
responsibility because whether you want
to or not you're gonna bump your elbow
and two billion people when they look at
their phone are gonna have thoughts and
start texting people that they wouldn't
have done if you hadn't you know made it
that way
and so how do we design devices
ethically and give parents in this
is better parental controls and make the
defaults good for everyone Jim you know
my kids are 10 my twins are 10 the ID
alone is 10 years old correct it's
interesting to always think about it in
that context right what are the studies
showing us about the effects of this
phone on us and our children
well basically more than 50% of kids
admit that they're addicted so that's a
pretty amazing thing and you as you can
imagine over 60% of parents say that
their kids are addicted but parents also
have to look in the mirror at their own
behavior because we all have issues I
think what the studies really show is
parents and kids and all of us need help
we really need to take this on this is
changing everything I mean look we all
know this is changing the nature of
interpersonal relationships the way you
manage your kids you can't get them away
from the screen or yourself
so I think it is time for us to have a
very important national conversation
that starts with families but also
schools and then going directly to the
industry and saying you have to change
your behavior don't you think they're on
board with it now do you think that
that's changing well I think we
certainly made an enormous momentum
since you know 60 minutes earlier this
year Roger McNamee Zuckerberg mentor
came out we've been partnering working
up a lot of this all together I think we
can think of this though is modeled
after the truth campaign with tobacco
it wasn't about whether or not it's
hurting people was about showing that
there's a deliberate attempt to hold on
to and grab people's attention that so
long as stock price is hooked to how
much attention I get you're gonna have
these kinds of problems and we're not
anti tech I mean if you you know common
transmedia we rate everything and we're
pro tech if used appropriately but this
is changing our culture and this is
happening and this is not a part of an
issue so our point is how do we help
people at home in school and then if
necessary going directly to the
companies ain't changing your practices
just on we talked we reached out to a
bunch of detect companies and Apple told
us it pardon me we think deeply about
how our products are used and the impact
they have on users and the people around
them
what can technologically be done to
break the the addiction to help with
this well first thing is that we can see
that companies like Apple and Samsung
are our friend they can do a lot more
because they make the device they don't
actually have to maximize how much yeah
on screen so they can do things like
giving parents better parental controls
and making default settings that so you
don't feel
constantly to get back to everybody so
ways that you can disconnect without
missing something important the key
thing though one thing that you can do
at home is you can actually set your
phone to grayscale and that really helps
because I did it myself if you set your
phone to grayscale which they can maybe
put up on the screen you go to general
you go to Settings General accessibility
display accommodations and then you say
set the colors to grayscale what this
does is when you look at your phone it's
all gray so when you look at your phone
normally you get those colorful icons
and all the red dots it feels like this
kind of addictive reward activates rich
I better do something lizard brain right
I better do something it activates all
the you take the grey out you make the
make it gray and suddenly it's just less
compelling it reminds you that it's just
a tool we should I want to point out
what Facebook said Jim they said we take
our responsibilities seriously we're
committed to being part of the
conversation Mark Zuckerberg seemed to
be reluctant in the beginning do you
think I think he's coming around you
know he's he always talks about his kids
I'm like good I'm glad you're talking
about your kids mark but here's the
thing you know I was here several years
ago talking about Facebook's role in
this and the arm is raised for attention
that's the bottom line is the people at
the top have to care so if Mark and
Sheryl Sandberg gets serious about this
and changed some of the practices at
Facebook and Instagram because they own
Instagram and if the folks who run
Google and the platforms that are based
on attention economy if they change that
and then the apples and the Samsungs
changed not just change the design but
also tell dumb people like me how do you
actually use it properly you can make
major changes next year but you have to
we have to hold their feet to the fire I
was changing the business model it I
look Facebook is an advertising business
model so as Google so they want you to
stay there that's how they make money
but I think it doesn't modifying the
business model and you know what society
and our kids are more valuable than
their business model right professor
yeah we have to leave it there thank you
very much thank you thank you guys for
having us